[Music]
my name is sarah drew and i am an art
conservator at center art studio in new
york city my team and i are going to
walk you through step by step how we
restore
a
250 plus year old french plaster and
gilt wood frame this frame was brought
to us by a private client along with a
painting that we will restore as well
the frame when it came to us was
extremely dirty
and it needed a lot of structural
repairs there was a lot of ornament that
was missing
[Music]
when we start cleaning the frame
we start with the back there's a lot of
resin on the back of the frame so we use
a scalpel
to scrape this resin off it's likely
some sort of polyurethane from
a previous restoration that stuff is
tricky to remove so
mechanically removing it with a scalpel
is the best approach
[Music]
once we have the back clean we flip the
frame right side up and we start the
front cleaning
[Music]
we commonly use cotton swabs to clean
the surface of a frame
but we also are going to be using micro
metal tools literally the same tools
that a dentist will use to really get
into all of the small little recesses
we use a variety of solvents which lift
the dirt up and allow us to then take
suaves to lift the dirt away
this frame was originally
water gilded which means
gold leaf was applied to it because of
that we have to be very careful with our
cleaning because
it would be very easy to remove that
original gilding
we never want to make something look
brand new
so
while we are going into the recesses and
we are removing the dirt
we don't want to entirely remove all of
that built up patina we want to retain
an element of age
[Music]
the main issue with the back of this
frame
is that it has been expanded to take a
larger piece of art than it was
originally built for
the first time we saw it we knew that we
were going to have to disassemble it and
build it back up properly
in order to
put the frame back properly we are using
a product called fish glue which is a
super condensed
fish product it's a very traditional
adhesive to use in conservation and it's
very strong
and then we align the frame
[Music]
once we feel that all the structural
work has been completed we move on to
filling in the missing areas of the
frame
three of the four corners are completely
missing their corner ornament
luckily we have one corner that is
completely intact that works to our
advantage in this case because we will
be able to take a silicone mold of this
corner and then cast plaster replicas of
it
to make a mold off the frame we use a
silicone compound once you have it mixed
together you can lay it over
a part of the frame that you want to
replicate
[Music]
it cures over
the course of about 20 or 30 minutes
once it's fully cured you can carefully
peel it off the frame
[Music]
and you will have the imprint of the
shape of the frame that you want to
replicate in that mold
we are using plaster to cast the molds
so we mix up a batch of plaster
[Music]
and we pour it into the silicone mold
[Music]
once the plaster has dried we can pop
that out of the mold
to prepare the frame to receive the
plaster casts we need to
remove some of the plastic material
that's already on it
we use a hammer and chisel to
carve away a recess that will allow the
past piece to
sit flush in the frame
we will shape and finesse these cast
pieces to make sure that they fit
properly in the areas where we're going
to be applying them
we use sandpaper in different grits
[Music]
we are using fish glue again to adhere
the cast pieces onto the frame
[Music]
when we feel like the frame is
physically complete it is time to move
on to the color work
the first layer of paint that we are
applying to the frame
is a primer
this is a venetian red primer and that
just creates a very nice red base layer
for us to work off of
we are gold leafing the ornaments in the
corners of this frame this is a process
called gilding
the frame was originally
gilded with gold leaf
and so whenever possible we like to use
the original materials in our
restoration just so the object has as
much integrity to the original as
possible
the first step to gilding
after you've applied the base layer is
to apply
a sizing medium
and this is brushed onto the plaster
and it is allowed to dry for about 30
minutes
it gets tacky
and once it's tacky it's in the right
state to accept the gold leaf
it is very very delicate so you can't
touch it with your hands it will just
crumble
so in order to handle it karen one of
our team members is using a horse hair
brush and lay it on to the ornament that
we want to guilt
we also will use squirrel hair brushes
to brush it on and make sure that it's
adhering to all of the recesses and all
of the areas of the frame
[Music]
once the gold leaf is applied we move on
to the in painting process
and we are going to paint over the gold
leaf to tone it down slightly and also
overall of the fills that we've made on
the frame and we use a combination
of conservation colors which are
paints that are specifically designed
for conservation work
it is literally a trial and error
process often we will make a color we'll
have to adjust it correct it a little
bit
this is where the frame starts to really
look like one whole object again
the next step is to apply a layer of
shellac
and this just serves as a top coat it
protects all of our work it also makes
everything just have a cohesive finish
and sheen
[Music]
we're really happy with how this
restoration came out we have done a lot
to restore the structural integrity
and the visual integrity of this frame
and we hope the client can enjoy the
frame for years to come
[Music]
you